and I met lots of people who were
suicidal because of that but also
unwilling to take care of themselves you
know because they were so guilty about
who they were and them and their mode of
being in the world that they just felt
that they weren't worth the damn trouble
you know and and well and they all had
their own particular reasons for for
believing that their own failures their
own improper sacrifices let's say their
own arts of individual malevolence but
they're summed up in a lovely
metaphorical manner a horrifying
metaphorical manner in those ancient
stories and those stories explain to us
too why as well that our consciences
don't sit well with us and why we always
feel that there's something undone that
we should be doing in the world which is
a much better pathway to take by the way
than to degenerate into nihilism and and
catastrophe and so and that's really
ruled - it's like well you should treat
yourself like you're someone responsible
for helping and the first question is
well why don't you and the answer is
well there's a lot wrong with you you
know and it's hard to exercise enough
love and care in a deep and non naive
way to care properly for something like
that but you know you do it for people
that you love despite their inadequacies
and there is this idea that there is a
spark of divinity within us and it is
possible that the fact that you have
that spark of divinity with you within
you also means that you have the
capability to withstand that terrible
vulnerability that's what I was trying
to get at in Chapter 1 which was to
stand up straight with your shoulders
back that you could actually voluntarily
accept the onslaught of the tragedy of
being and that you can constrain the
proclivity for malevolence that's part
of you and that's part of the world and
in that you can discover your own
you your own intrinsic value in your own
nobility and and all of that might be
more powerful than the forces of
vulnerability and malevolence themselves
which I also happen to believe and I
think that that is in some sense the
fundamental hallmark of faith and so
chapter two and to some degree chapter
three wishes to surround yourself with
people who want the best for you is a
it's an encouragement to assume to act
out the proposition that even if life is
as difficult as it seems to be and if
you're as vulnerable and weak in a
fundamental sense as you definitely are
and characterized by this terrible
propensity for the infliction of
voluntary suffering on yourself and
others and that destructive tendency
that there's still something within you
that's so remarkable and so aligned with
with order and being in the proper
manner that you can climb above that
let's say like able and that you can
make the proper sacrifices and that you
can set yourself right and you can set
your family right and you can set the
world right and that the mere
possibility that that might occur that
that might be within the realm of
potential means that you have a moral
obligation to exercise the
responsibility to take care of yourself
as if you're something that matters and
that if you did that properly it might
turn out that what you did would matter
that it would matter to you that it
would be meaningful in the way that
things that matter are meaningful and
that it would matter to everyone around
you